buenas tardes el rol dentro de la
familia real británica del duque de
edimburgo fue uno y uno muy simple ser
el soporte la columna vertebral de
isabel segunda durante todo su reinado
felipe de edimburgo se encargó cuando
isabel segunda asumió la corona de las
labores más domésticas de la crianza de
la educación de los cuatro hijos que
tuvieron pero también tuvo una labor
filantrópica muy destacada siendo patrón
de más de 800 organizaciones de caridad
tanto en el reino unido y a nivel
internacional y también los expertos
aseguran que filipe el príncipe felipe
se encargó de modernizar la familia real
haciéndola un poco más accesible al
público y luisa contanos qué
repercusiones podemos destacar al
momento en la sociedad británica también
en el arco político por supuesto
sí por supuesto se vive en este momento
un luto nacional el duque de edimburgo y
la reina isabel tiene en gran estima de
gran parte de los británicos no otros
figuras de la familia real pero por
supuesto se vive un luto nacional desde
esta mañana no se conocen los detalles
todavía del funeral pero se cree que
será en ocho días y será de carácter más
privado pese a que el duque de edimburgo
por ser el príncipe consorte tendría
derecho a un funeral de estado él mismo
expresó a sus cercanos que preferiría un
funeral militar dado que su corazón
estaba muy cercano a las fuerzas
militares tuvo una carrera muy destacada
hasta los años 50 en la armada británica
especialmente exitosa en la segunda
guerra mundial el funeral entonces sería
además privado por las actuales
condiciones del confinamiento que vive
en inglaterra donde a partir del lunes
máximo 30 personas podrán reunirse para
un funeral en este periodo de duelo
nacional que se extenderá hasta un día
después del funeral los edificios
les tienen las banderas a media asta la
abadía de westminster ha iniciado a
partir de esta hora y cada hora
campanazos durante 99 veces para
acelerar cada año de vida del duque se
ha suspendido también la campaña
electoral de las elecciones regionales
previstas para el 6 de mayo los
ministros del gabinete no darán
entrevistas y la reina isabel ha
suspendido sus funciones es decir que no
firmara leyes y el parlamento estará
reunido a partir del lunes para rendir
un mensaje un tributo al príncipe felipe
los diputados y lores llevarán
brazaletes negros y corbatas negros la
familia real como dices ha agradecido
estos sentimientos de solidaridad esas
expresiones del público que ha llevado
flores a las afueras del castillo de
windsor donde murió el duque esta mañana
y también del palacio de buckingham pero
le ha pedido a la población que no se
reúna en grandes grupos especialmente
por esta pandemia que estamos viviendo
aquí en inglaterra y generalmente en
estos casos se habilita un libro de
condolencias pero éste ya ha sido
lanzado en internet así que cualquier
persona desde cualquier país
y expresar sus sentimientos de
condolencia a la familia real luisa
pulida muchísimas gracias por este
completísimo deporte desde el reino
unido